what are the future trajectories that
lead to a potential war with china
cold war
or hot war is this something you think
about is this something you're worried
about
yeah i'd like to talk about both wars so
the war with china
as i say there are five kinds of wars
there's a trade war tech um technology
war
geopolitical influence war
um capital war
and military war
i um as far as military war goes i only
i think it's only a taiwan issue
um but that's a big issue
and we could talk about that for a
minute but those others they'll be uh
rough competitions
um and will have that type of evolution
over a period of time that's what
that war looks like
taiwan has been
for a long time
um
a sovereignty issue to china
and it has its roots in what's called
the 100 years of humiliation
um from the 1840s to 1949
foreign powers came in took advantage of
china um they had the opium wars and
such times and
and that represented the 100 years of
humiliation
and
taiwan um
represents his
their sovereignty and
their important thing and
50 years ago starting 50 years ago there
was an agreement that there is one china
and
taiwan is part of china
and that
there would be
peaceful reunification
the
the peaceful reunification hasn't
happened and in their view
that's a very big issue and so it's a
big contentious issue
and that could produce a military war
um could produce a military accident
could produce a it's a very tense
situation and if we had a military war
god help us
because of the capacity in all different
new ways to inflict
harm on each other but anyway that's
that's that if you don't have that
military war you'll have the competition
between
those other kinds of wars and whoever is
strongest in those areas will um win
where do you put cyber war within the
five
well cyber war is a military war i'm
assuming the type of cyber war that
you're using you're referring to is that
which it's used to inflict pain on the
other party through cyber so cyber wars
you'll see cyber war
you could see space war
you can see drone warfare
you um new types of warfare not just
the traditional and nuclear type of
warfare
but you could see any of the above
you